in today's world of Big Data storing
organizing and analyzing data is
critical and it impacts many Industries
such as Finance retail marketing and
even Healthcare
without the right data infrastructure
companies and industries are under
utilizing that data they collect and
waste valuable space
as a data engineer you build the engine
that helps companies manage all of that
data and they are crucial to any
company's data strategy that's why here
at Udacity we created this data
engineering with AWS nanodegree program
in this program you will learn how to
design data models build data warehouses
and data Lakes automate data pipelines
and work with massive data sets you will
also apply these skills immediately on
various Hands-On projects tailored for
this program where you will act as a
data engineer using data engineering
tools
by the end of this program you will be
able to create a create database in
Apache Cassandra Implement a data
warehouse on AWS based on the redshift
architecture use spark to work with data
sets and use Apache airflow to schedule
automate and monitor data Pipelines
Advance your career in today's
data-driven Workforce and sign up for
udacity's data engineering with AWS
nanodegree program